dee
ています
ます
私はキノコマイスターです
今はこうしてみなさんの前でお話しする機会も多くなりましたが実は子供のころは口を
開けるのは給食や物を食べる時だけっていうとってもおとなしい症状でした
そんな私がどうしてキノコマイスターになったか
キノコを食べると変更になれる
痩せてキレイになれるという噂を信じて私は毎日
キノコを食べました
火の粉には水に溶ける健康成分もありますのでスープがおすすめです
そして1年が経ったある日
上野さん綺麗になったね何かやってるのっ
惹かれるようになりますが
私は自分の経験からキノコの魅力の話をせざるにはいられませんでした
もうキノコの話ばかりしちゃいました
日の子ってすごいんです
すごいんですすごいんですよみんな見ました
そして1ヶ月で1キロのペースで痩せていき
気がついた時には10キロ痩せていました
その後能健康診断では
肥満と言われていた体重が標準体重になり
コレステロール値は正常という結果が出て驚いてきましたいます
私にとって
でも驚いたんですけれども
火の粉が私の人生を変えました
そしてもっと前を向いてもいいんじゃないって
皆さんにも私にとってのキノコのようなものありますよね
火の粉にはたくさんのを様々な健康の成分があります
それで今日はこれを立証にどのように取り入れたらよいかという方法をみなさんにをご
紹介したいと思います
全国のキノコの平均消費量は16グラムと言われています
私たち
きのこマイスターはもっともっと健康長寿を目指して1日100グラムを目標にしてい
ます
100g というとこれぐらいになります
そしてみんなが電子レンジで1分間加熱調理したようになります
これくらいなら毎日食べられそうな量ですよね
このキノコをもっと効率よく体内に吸収するにはどうしたらいいた
まずは細かく切るそして
いる
凍らせるです
この全てを取り入れたのはえのき氷です
長野県中野市発祥のこのえのき氷は
とても簡単に作れます
ヒール
水を入れてミキサーにかけ
塗る
そして粗熱をとって凍らせる
これがえのき氷です
とても簡単に作れますし手軽にポンと使えそうですよね
このえのき氷ですが解けるととろみがあります
このとろみ感触が何かに入れてるな
そうだ玉藻だと思いつきまして
それならフライなどにパン粉をつけるときに使えるんじゃないか
絶対いいねぇと思って学校給食の卵アレルギーの子どもたちにどうかという提案をした
ところ
シュウマイや火の粉が嫌いでも気づかずにいただける
スープなどに汁物頭に練ったれていることが分かりました
卵アレルギーということでその子供たちも
頃を悩ませて悩んで
どんな時もあったと思うんです
でもこのえのき氷で
ずっとねその子供たちもエゴにできると願っています
子供だけでなく大人でもアレルギーで悩んでいる方ぜひお勧めしたいと思います
そしてニューつ名前日にサヨナラしてっ
元気でイキイキと過ごしていただきたいのです
それが私の駒井さんに与えられた使命だと感じています
まだまだ火の粉の秘められたパワーについてたくさんお話ししたいことがあるんです
けど今日は中野氏発祥のえのき氷についてお話しさせていただきました
火の粉はヒカルに食べれて
とっても体にいい食材だということを忘れないでください
そうだ火の粉を食べよう
へのティ号にもあですね
ということで
この日本のキノコが世界の多くの皆様の目に触れる機会もそう遠くで遠くはないのでは
ないかと感じています
その時はぜひこのえのき氷の作り方にチャレンジしてみていただきたいと思います
以上ですありがとうございました